I learned that men who have a dad bod
type physique which would be a higher
deposits of gut fat
um they are seen they are judged by both
men and women as being better fathers
you think hang on a second how is it
that a guy that has a dad bod like oh
the dad bod thing's actually real but
it's real in Reverse it's not that Dad
bods are attractive it's that Dad bods
make better dads the reason for this it
seems is that both men and women look at
a guy who has a dad bod
and they see somebody who has fewer
doors open to him where he could spend
calories that he gets so if you have
some guy that's good looking and in
really great shape and that man has a
wife and or a partner ancestrally and a
couple of kids he could spend any energy
that he wants on them but he might also
be able to spend his energy chasing some
other women around because he is
sufficiently attractive to bring them in
however the guy who has the dad bod
presumably has fewer doors open to him
where he could stray from what is family
investment with regards to the calories
so men that have Dad bods are perceived
as being better fathers mostly because
they have fewer options open to them
that they could stray from their family
with
so would it be is it's very specific to
being fathers or is it more specific to
becoming fathers and essentially being a
life partner because they don't teach
them their security uh yes that's
interesting I don't think that this is
I don't think that you're going to end
up with women being more attracted to
dads with Dad bods because they see
better parental investment future
parental investment from them I think
that it's very difficult to bypass uh
desire right like you're just attracted
to what you're attracted to and this is
why when it comes to attraction people
can try and
um logically reason their way in or out
of whatever it is that they want
ultimately you end up liking what you
like and it's very difficult to change
that around this is more other people's
judgments of the father however I
definitely think that there is
an interesting argument to be made that
um
I I have a friend whose ex-girlfriend
said to him when he was getting leaner
he trains in the gym a lot and as he was
getting leaner and getting into better
and better condition that she became
less and less happy and less comfortable
in their relationship and she said the
happiest I ever was was with you was
when you were fat and the reason for
this presumably is that some partners
and this will be the same for both men
and women you know if your partner has a
glow up there is something called mate
value which is your own and everybody
else's subjective interpretation of your
value within the mating Market if your
make value starts to increase the
partner if they don't increase theirs
along with you will start to feel that
Delta between you right they're going to
start to feel you pull away from them
and they're gonna go oh no this is going
to cause anxiety especially if they've
got anxious attachment
it's just going to cause all sorts of
problems so yeah there is definitely an
argument to be made that um some
relationships can be made to feel more
secure if one of the partners is getting
less attractive or becomes less
attractive because it is more secure to
the other one what's your experience Ben
I don't I don't really know about
whether or not what I've done in terms
of make value has
cause problems in relationships I do
quite I try and do quite a good job of
making whoever it is that I'm with feel
comfortable so I try and compensate as
hard as I can
um but I mean there's there's so many
interesting things I learned recently
about
um the birth control pill hormonal birth
control have you had a look at much of
this about the psychological effect on
women oh my God I mean I was on it for
16 years and I'm not with any of those
guys anymore so I'm like ah [ __ ] maybe
it did make me maybe there's something
to it yeah it changes it changes uh
pheromones and so it changes who I I'm I
can't remember it's the person it's like
the girl taking it chooses differently
when she's on versus off right doesn't
have to do with the guy it's the girl
well both it seems both um yeah so
typically when we think about men and
women you have women are The Gatekeepers
and men are the protagonists right like
women of the supply and Men of the
demand when it comes to sex for the most
part and this is you you know that this
is the case but because in gay
relationships there's no gatekeeper
anymore which is why gay men have tons
and tons of sex
um so
it seems like women who are on hormonal
birth control prioritize providers
rather than protectors when it comes to
mates so they will look for a
provisioning man one who is higher in
terms of monetary wealth and ability to
gain resources but will de-prioritize
masculinity dominance status stuff like
that
um that means that women who are on
birth control can prioritize a partner
and then when they come off birth
control find out that the things that
they prioritized aren't any longer the
things that they're bothered about
self-reports from women that use natural
cycles which is a cycle tracking app
have said that
their self-rated sexual satisfaction
with Partners if they met them when they
were on and are now off is way down
compared with women who met them when
they were off and are now still off and
the reason being that they've
prioritized for things that didn't
necessarily sort of get them excited in
the bedroom now there is a mediator here
and it's whether or not the partner that
the woman uh gets into a relationship
with is attractive remembering that she
hasn't been as bothered by his level of
attractiveness when she first met him
but that doesn't mean that she didn't
find an attractive partner she still
could have found a very attractive
partner but he was really good at
provisioning right he was really good at
earning money or doing whatever then she
gets out of this hormonal birth control
in induced stupor enters into the world
and goes oh holy [ __ ] I've got this
really attractive partner let's have
loads of sex so it basically seems that
some women had a better time and some
had a worse time but for the most part
you can have a woman that is attracted
to you on birth control comes off and
then the relationship doesn't work so
well anymore which is a bad time for
both parties I think there's so much in
that area especially with women I feel
like in various different things
that we don't know about I mean just
even the fact that you're not having a
regular cycle you're not having a cycle
you're having like a withdrawal bleed on
it I mean women just don't know that you
you know you're put on it to regulate
your hormones oh if you have a regular
period just put you on that and they're
like basically just taking it away what
was your experience of coming off it
like everything was very normal for like
six months and
um then I met someone I dated him for
about a year Health stuff got pretty
wonky after about six months hormones
thyroid all kinds of various different
symptoms gut you name it it was a pretty
it's been a pretty big roller coaster
um so I feel like it's it's detrimental
I mean probably to what level I don't
know yet it's a massively difficult
conversation right let's say that you've
got a daughter who's 12 or 13 years old
you know that she's going to be sexually
active within the next five years or
something like that so you go okay
um do I want to roll the dice with my
daughter who definitely doesn't have the
same amount of life experience about
being safe and protection and stuff like
that than I do as someone who's been
around for a lot longer uh do I want to
roll the dice by not putting her on
birth control or do I want to put her in
birth control knowing that I'm
condemning her to this very different
very unhappy psychological profile and
one of the really worrying things is
that it seems like girls that are going
through puberty who go on birth control
because their brains are at this
formative stage of development you can
lock in changes to the brain that are
irreversible when you come off birth
control okay well then let's have a like
a bit more of a philosophical
conversation about you know I've been
thinking about this myself like there's
really only a few days during the month
you can get pregnant let's calm five or
so days that are you're fertile and sex
is just something that just can happen
right it's just like you know it's like
tagged as women's freedom and Liberation
to be able to do what you want when you
want but what if what if it's a complete
like cultural reframing where it goes to
something that isn't just everyday any
day whenever you want like can't there I
I feel like if there was a conversation
and a cultural shift around how it's
perceived and when you do it like all of
a sudden like abstinence makes the heart
grow fonder imagine make it you know
when you have to make someone wait it's
so great even yourself so what if now it
just became this really like much more
like valuable rare thing it would be so
much better
are you proposing that the entire world
limit having sex to just when women are
ovulating yeah no when they're not
unless they want to have a baby like oh
right okay so you mean okay right but
what would be the reason for that other
than just for protection like what
wouldn't have to be on birth control
right so you'd be much more safe from a
pregnancy standpoint so the narrative
changes around sex to being something
that's done you know at specific times
you would now as a woman track your
cycle more you'd understand the four
cycles of your cycle men would too
because you have it in a day a 24-hour
cycle we'd be invested yes you'd
understand
we'd have to yeah because we want to get
we want to get our underweight yeah I
mean I don't know I think
it would be an interesting
an interesting experiment to try and run
but when people want it they want it you
know and especially given the fact that
women's sex drive women's desire for
more masculine men women's desire for
more dominance in men for men with more
masculinized faces all of this stuff
increases precisely during the time when
you're telling them to not have sex like
the person that gets damaged the most by
this philosophy by your tyrannical new
sex policy
is the the people that are going to be
the most damaged by this are the women
because when sex arrive is highest
you're going to say let's try and let's
try and push this down so that's going
to be very difficult but I mean here's
an interesting philosophical question
right a difficult one maybe
should women even if they're on birth
control have sex with men who they would
not get into a relationship with or who
they would not marry
[Music]